what's good all right let's open the dm
it was a big mistake that was a big
mistake
someone said
hi
would you not allow a white girlfriend
to call you [ __ ]
i'm white my boyfriend is mixing from
the hood and we call each other racial
slurs playfully he started it
and obviously neither of us would do it
around other people
maybe it's just so genuine but i'm
wondering if you would find something
inherently wrong with it
thank you for taking the time to read
this
good day [ __ ]
she said good thing
did she say good day
no no
that would have been
on point that would have been one of the
funniest dm's i've ever seen wow
hey man listen
i'd be like
this is just me what you guys doing i'll
probably see your bedroom in between
y'all that's y'all okay i'm not gonna go
you wanna do a race play you got y'all
got some weird fetishes maybe like
listen if you call your girl [ __ ]
that's weird
hey [ __ ] sit on my head
that's weird bruh
that's weird i'm sorry bro i can't don't
hey little [ __ ] you wanna sit on my
picks
oh man now you're asking me percy hell
no i'm not i'm not comfortable with that
weird i would question any white woman
who really wanted to say that exactly
that that's what makes me suss about
yeah you know what i'm saying
because i've see i've heard it sometimes
like i'm just like watching a prawn
video right and the girl's like yeah let
me let me let me let me suck that [ __ ]
dick oh my what
why am i hard
at a weirder phone yeah like yeah okay
this didn't make me soft at all but you
know what it's not even just that it's
like also a girl's like she wants to
like start calling me daddy no oh that
no that's a no bro no okay can i sit on
your lap daddy no what would you like
better
no
what you like better no you don't have
whatever you said no would you have no
choice
[ __ ]
daddy which is it
[Laughter]
i'm
this video is brought to you by
manscape manscape has everything you
need to keep it clean and when i'm
talking about keeping it clean i'm
talking about under you know under the
sea little mermaid keeping your
seashells by the seashore if you will
first and foremost trim your booty
to trim your booty
we have the lawnmower 4.0 you could use
it underwater there's a guard for you
not to check your bottles you know
because you don't want to chip them you
know what i mean you want them nice and
clean there's two products that are
wonderful too the crop preserver and the
tonic for your crop well the preserver
is basically a deodorant you can't
always just put
water and soap under your armpits right
sometimes you need deodorant your tinga
ling ling is the same you use the
preserver just as a deodorant and if
ever you're on the go you can use a
tonic to have a little freshen up snip
snip let it dry and you're good to go
and right now you can get 20 off plus
international free shipping plus two
gifts by manscape if you go today on
manscape.com and you use promo code
preach that's
p-r-e-a-c-h you already i'm sorry
i'm sorry
you know what if you're if you're
watching a [ __ ] show
you're watching right now what would you
choose option one
daddy option two
[Music]
man i don't know
oh
oh this one's in the books
yeah
yeah that's just a no so those are were
you thinking about it are you bothering
about it i was like
oh [ __ ]
oh no let's leave it no that's weird
here's why it's weird
first off it's not like i would go crazy
or lose my mind but i'm like why do you
want to say so badly just like [ __ ] my
dick you crack your ass cracker
can you chill um
yeah this is weird you know what i mean
no
that's weird
y'all that's your business
don't though that's your business that
yeah that's your best that's weird
though that's not us yeah i would try to
figure out why you like want to say it
so badly but i'm not here to tell people
what words they can or can't say so you
do you but that's funny that's weird
using the word [ __ ] in in a bedroom
context it sounds weird to me yeah it is
hey [ __ ] let me sit on your lap
oh my god i also wouldn't be like hey
man somebody crackers like that's weird
i don't know why that's weird maybe
that's part of like role play if you
were getting into it super weird i don't
know that's weird what do you what are
your thoughts of somebody who's like you
know you deal with that no just no
no no oh just no no just know it's just
someone that brings up the question uh
can i call you
what the [ __ ] did you say to me no
no no this is a [ __ ] out of you i'm just
thinking about the white women i have
dated i just imagined them calling me
things no
no no no it's not happening yeah that's
not happening it's not happening we're
not doing this yeah that's weird but
anyways let us know which one you guys
would pick we want to hear from you guys
in the comments below